compétences connaître et gentillesse
passionné
c'est luthier et c'est aussi ma plus
grande passion on est à Pierrefond et on
est précisément donc dans une zone où il
y a un très gros projet et c'est un
petit peu le village de Gaulois là chez
moi
donc là vous êtes dans ma maison atelier
donc ça c'est une guitare qui est qui
ressemble à une guitare électrique mais
qui est en fait une guitare totalement
acoustique j'avais 16 ans et il a fallu
que je me pose sérieusement la question
qu'est-ce que je vais faire donc j'ai
pas forcément choisi la voie la plus
facile à travers ce métier
tu me trouves un peu de travail max tu
vas bien je te pose une colle quelle
bosser pour toi
alors ça c'est je te le dis
là haut on a des bois qui sont
similaires ici à des bois extrêmement
recherchés dans le monde et mais après
il n'y a pas que les bois précieux qui
ont un intérêt il y a des bois qu'on ne
crypto-méria qui est mon préféré avec le
tamarin
il connaît comment je joue il connaît ma
pain et comme ça hein ma sensibilité
m'appelle il connaît donc quand je donne
une guitare pour faire il connaît à quoi
s'en tenir
j'ai mis à la
page
parce que tu fais là dans tout ce
boucles
parce que c'est parti pour une bonne
soirée rock tout le matériel qui a ici
date d'avant 90 voir 1980 quoi on
utilise le talent de ceux qui savent
donc ça peut être des luthiers des
techniciens et puis derrière c'est des
hommes derrière des instruments et fait
de bois et voilà j'aimerais vraiment
faire découvrir qu'est-ce que c'est que
l'univers de guitares du son tout ce
qu'on peut exprimer
à travers ce métier